und jetzt wird wirklich romantisch lasst
sie uns bitte mal über den wald reden
muss ich den jungen zuschauern
vielleicht erklären wald das ist dieser
diffuse grüne klumpen mit schlechtem
wlan wo ihr sonntags immer spazieren
gehen müsst zusammen mit den geräumten
vista ja dieser mystische ort wo sich
unsere kinder verlaufen und von hexen
gemästet werden aber ich komme ins
schwärmen ich komme ins schwärmen wir
deutschen lieben wald wir lieben
deswegen machen uns ja diese bilder aus
brasilien gerade so fertig auf tausenden
quadratkilometern brennt der regenwald
sehr wahrscheinlich angezündet von
pharma die neue weideflächen wollen
angestiftet mindestens ermuntert von
brasiliens präsident ball zu nahrung für
den die fakten zum klimawandel nur
menschen gemachte fake news sind und zum
glück hat der ball so längst
herausgefunden wer wirklich hinter
diesen bränden steckt die
umweltorganisationen verlieren geld also
fahren sie die feuer an damit sie die
internationale aufmerksamkeit auf
brasilien lenken können
macht sinn nicht so sind sie die
umweltschützer
wenn sie nicht gerade nach vorne
abknallen zünden sie regenwälder
jawoll so nahrung für mich so was wie
der lord voldemort brasiliens hält
übrigens auch die indigenen völker am
amazonas für verkleidete umweltschützer
und es leider kein witz meine damen und
herren
brandrodung ein neuer frecher trend
bestimmt bald auch bei uns fuß
brandrodung set die lösung aller
probleme in haushalt und garten schnauze
voll vom ständigen rasen mähen dann
versuchs doch mal mit brandrodung schon
wieder kein parkplatz frei vor deinem
haus
da hilft nur eins brand roten die
verdammten plagen räumen ihr zimmer auf
müssen sie auch gar nicht mag dir das
leben leichter wenn es dich abfackelt ab
antwort ja
wirklich schlimm was da passiert ganz
schlimm
wichtiger co2 speicher für den ganzen
planeten und wie schön wäre das wenn man
jetzt entspannt auf die brasilianer
schimpfen könnte leider geht es auch
unserem wald grad nicht so gut hitze
stürme schädlinge allein seit 2008 zehn
sind 100 10.000 hektar deutscher weit
verloren gegangen wenn das so weiter
geht dann sind wir bald ein volk ohne
baum es ist ja so jetzt die gute
nachricht unsere
landwirtschaftsministerin frau klöckner
hat die dringlichkeit des problems
längst erkannt wir haben eine zäsur
draußen im wald und jeder der augen und
ohren hat sieht das ja steht ja schon im
kleinen prinzen man sieht nur mit den
ohren gut immerhin eine halbe milliarde
euro hat frau klöckner für die
wiederaufforstung in deutschland
beantragt man es schön noch schöner wäre
wenn die kohle nach ökologischen
vorgaben verteilt würde denn da liegt
unser fehler und zwar der letzten 30 40
jahre profitorientierte monokultur mit
schneisen für große monster maschinen
auf denen forstarbeiter durch den wald
brettern sehen sie überall und ungerade
gerade reine kiefer und fichte bilder
von denen wir ohne ende haben die sind
sehr anfällig für klimawandel und
borkenkäfer was alleine borkenkäfer
zerstören diese holz angels der wälder
ja wirklich die viecher fressen
ausgetrocknete bäume oder ist die angst
vor einem neuen waldsterben eventuell
übertrieben dass die wälder werden nicht
per sie sterben ich möchte auch den
begriff überhaupt nicht verwenden weil
die welle wenn sich verändern
eben
keine sorge jessica opa ist nicht
gestorben er hat sich verändert
deswegen laden wir den nicht mehr so oft
zum kaffee
50 prozent des deutschen waldes die
hälfte gehört jetzt schon privatleuten
und einige dieser privatleute haben
aktuell echte probleme für tannenbaum
züchter wie august klein rechts sich
hingegen der ungewöhnlich trockene
sommer neuer verlangt so hier müsste
einen stehen
aber das steht ja keiner
ich glaube die versteckt sich nur
wirklich nicht kommt dir aus so und wenn
sie jetzt denken wenn sie jetzt denken
der staat ist garantiert der bessere
waldbesitzer leider nein leider gar
nicht schon 2007 hat die damalige groko
seiner zeit hier ist die kanzlerin noch
merkel
hat das ziel gesetzt bis zum jahr 2020
dass wir nächstes jahr 5% 5 prozent der
deutschen wälder zu naturwäldern zu
machen sprich in ruhe zu lassen heute
sind es 2,8 prozent in ganz deutschland
ja unterschied nur bayern in bayern sind
ziemlich nur 1,3 schlusslicht besonders
abschreckendes beispiel das schutzgebiet
hoher buchenwald mit 775 hektar umfasste
er ganze 0,6 prozent des naturparks
steigerwald dennoch klagten die
bayerischen staatsforsten wegen der
einnahmeausfälle
am ende wurde der schutzstatus wieder
aufgehoben was soll denn das warum
müssen wälder die uns allen gehören
gewinn machen ist doch blödsinn
haben sie jetzt in bayern endlich
geändert in anderen bundesländern aber
eben noch nicht um auf die
privatbesitzer zurückzukommen deren
lobbyverband fordert gerade vom staat
2,3 milliarden euro soforthilfe wegen
der aktuellen schäden deutlich mehr als
bei klöckner anbietet christian freiherr
von mering ist waldbesitzer in vierter
generation hervor mehring das ist aber
eine stolze summe dafür müsst ihr dann
aber auch aufhören mit der ganzen
monokultur denn der wald gehört uns ja
irgendwo auch allen bitte sie gerade mit
der zeitmaschine aus der ddr gekommen
oder was mein wald gehört gar nicht
allen der gehört mir deswegen heißt da
ja mein wald
urgroßvater ehring hat ihn damals
gekauft und dann hat großvater hering
mit hilfe von polnischen zwangsarbeitern
ich ja auch egal
fakt ist meine bäume speichern hier co2
das sind zwei milliarden ja wohl das
mindeste ja klar aber geld verdienen
können sie doch auch mit naturnahen wald
naturnaher wald wenn ich die scheiße
schon höre
dummes städter gequatsche was ist denn
bitte so romantisch am deutschen wald
das ist ja noch holzfabrik der baum ist
eine evolutionäre zwischenstufe auf dem
weg zum billy regal so er hat keine
gefühle
dieses große waldwesen wahrzunehmen und
mich da einfach willkommen zu fühlen das
ist das ist einfach total schön
total schön für mich ist das bau
missbrauch hashtag twitter ich habe eine
idee ich nehme demnächst eintritt von
diesen ökos einmal baum geschützt den
euro deutschlands erster waldhof ja
es ist doch schön dass wir so ein
emotionales verhältnis zum baum haben
acht wir sind ein volk von heuchlern
schon wieder waldsterben
dabei haben alle wieder den ganzen
sommer durch gegrillt schön ein schwein
nach dem anderen aufs garten krematorium
geworfen stiftung warentest hat bei
grillkohle stichproben in einem drittel
der produkte tropenholz gefunden stört
aber kein oder haben sie deswegen
aufgehört zu grillen ich jetzt höre ich
persönlich klar ja das ging ja nicht
weil ganz genau
jedes jahr 250.000 tonnen grillkohle
allein in deutschland wenn wir die nur
aus deutschen holz machen würden dann
wäre das eine waldfläche von einer
halben million fußballfelder so viele
tote bäume nur für ferkel tessas mit
ketchup
aber mir vorträge über monokultur halten
ich hab's doch eben sagt monokultur
macht den wald anfälliger für
klimawandel und bogen gebe es fakt also
wegen der borkenkäfer müssen sie sich
keine sorgen mehr machen die viecher
sind erledigt bäume fällen statt panzer
fahren in sachsen sind jetzt erstmals
auch bundeswehrsoldaten gegen
borkenkäfer einsatz die operation anti
brumm hat begonnen
unter diesem namen läuft der kampf gegen
den borkenkäfer operation anti brumm
keiner namen haben sie noch nie von
alleine berater ausgedacht für drei
millionen
ich sage ihnen der kampf gegen den
borkenkäfer das wird der erste krieg
sein den die deutschen gewinnen wir
jetzt die wollen alle borkenkäfer
einzeln erschießen ein quatsch das sind
g36 gewehre die schießen doch nicht
[Applaus]
vor sich da wird eine abhauen christian
vom ehrenmal damen und herrenteam hans
de schreibt über die heute show ihr seid
die richtigen links [ __ ] besonders
welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal